[Music]
located along the black fork of the
mohican river is the small town of
loudounville home to landau's mohican
castle
after selling their profitable printing
business owners jim and martin landau
built the castle on a lush 1100 acre
state in the heart of rural ohio jim and
i ran a coloring book publishing
business we did sell it i assumed we
would retire
but jim had other
ideas
my dad told himself that if he ever made
any kind of money someday
he would build a castle and he made
money and
built a castle
between the castle and restaurant the
official total was in the six million
dollar range
[Music]
in 2008 our
beautiful
restaurant burned to the ground
my husband he had let the insurance
lapse unfortunately it was only four
days prior
it was a very really bad day
[Music]
we burned down in may and jim and i
separated in june
we were divorced within the year
jim retired and now
it's all on my shoulders
marta does everything here
she works oh my gosh harder than anybody
i think on the property
she
runs around like crazy there's not a day
that she's not working
from sun up until sundown
she could be retired she could be
relaxing somewhere enjoying her
grandkids but instead
it's almost like she's a prisoner here
so
i think that we really need jimmy to
manage the property
jimmy's the general manager in title
only he's more the cook here on the
property it says two uh or one
tablespoon of worcestershi worst chester
or whatever you call it we don't really
honestly take him seriously but
we've never had a reason to i guess take
him seriously
are we supposed to clean up now
because he's the baby born with a silver
spoon in his mouth that everybody's
always done everything for him what is
honey glazed carrots i've actually never
made those marta does baby jimmy and
that causes jimmy to not really have to
step up and be a general manager
[Music]
we keep thinking what what can we do
what can we do to get
more you know more customers in the
restroom what can we do to get more
people at the hotel it has such
potential
one of my main concerns is that i do
want to be able to
make this place successful and be able
to
retire but it is a struggle you know
because
a lot of times i don't see a lot of
light at the end of the tunnel
[Music]
i'm here in ohio i'm heading to a castle
that's right a castle but it's actually
built by a local businessman he's no
longer involved and he's left the
property to his ex-wife and his son to
run
here we are
castle up ahead for that
wow
the grounds are stunning
o n g look at this place what an amazing
setting really beautiful
[Music]
hello hello my goodness me
gordon nice to see you nice to meet you
um this place is incredible when was it
built
they started construction in 1996 we
opened in 2002. wow how long have you
been here i've been here for 10 years
and all this sort of
junk what happens to that stuff this is
our little gift shop oh wow yeah oh so
this is a gift shop bits of sort of
knickknacks
but they seem odd what about these
i haven't sold any of the reading
sunglasses and what's that
that is the cd we have in our rooms
the cd celtic mystique we have music
playing in our suites when you arrive
wow um i didn't know people buy cds
anymore
wow 16. is it good
i've listened to it for 10 years i don't
hear it anymore most of the time what a
strange little nicknack shop
and what's over here um all the beer and
wine that we sell
well you see the dust on top of there
everything's so dusty
who's in charge of cleaning i'm slacking
on my job i appreciate the odd speckle
of dust on the wine the wine cellar not
not like this wow and look at that when
is that from 1980 what
you laugh but it is a little out of date
right oh yeah definitely out of date and
dusty dusty the actual tv was on you
couldn't see it because the dust
um so it looks like it was high-end to
build really expensive but yes doesn't
look like we've had enough
money going back into it to keep it sort
of where how it where it needs to be how
it should be right and what's over here
um
one of the weddings we had on the
property this place must be packed they
do 30 to 50 a year who runs those melody
is our events coordinator and she's a
specialist in events and um she was
never like trained or anything but how
can you run events have you not been
trained
common sense sometimes prevails um
now what's that there landlords mohegan
castle win a night state
stop you know many people want a free
night seriously yeah we try to do it
once a month shall i do one yes please
[Music]
love this love it
ready so
all right
that's fantastic
is there a cell number on there
um
thank you
arts machine
chuck congratulations you have won
yourself a free night stay at landau's
mohican castle courtesy
of me gordon ramsay
free dinner
dinner's not included no chuck i'm so
sorry i don't want to piss on your
bonfire but there's no dinner involved
but i'll pay for dinner chuck best
wishes
he's going to be so happy when he hears
that [ __ ] message
excellent uh
amazing it's cluttered and it's dusty
damn so you've been here 10 years what
other problems just little things here
and there that need to be updated most
of it's still from when we opened
originally so 13 years old
now the owner is no longer involved in
the business he's left at timmy's
ex-wife marta jim's ex-wife right she
runs it now with her son who's the
general manager correct right and what's
his strengths
um
i can't tell you business-wise
management-wise if jimmy really in my
opinion has any strengths at this point
he has the title general manager but i
don't think he really fully has that
role of general manager yet he went off
to train at hotel school where did he
come from no jimmy has no training
outside of high school mata the sheet
no
she has no training he has no training
who's more hands-on marta is hands-on
marta is here there and everywhere and
she
she's like the busy bee that never stops
is she around
um i'm sure she's on the property let me
thank you
um i'm gonna just check around outside
and i look forward to uh
seeing marla thank you you're welcome
hey is marta down there wow this place
costs a fortune what is up here okay can
you send her up gordon would like to
meet her look at that
wow
what in the [ __ ] is that over there
it's our t-rex what is that thing
here
ugh
i love these flies
[Music]
bloody hell
look at that
so you relax and take your cigarette
breaks
oh
jesus christ
i love these flies that is disgusting
this is a place where people come to
relax
what
man that's gross
seriously
ugh
horrible
wow
hello hello
you must be mata i'm marta you must be
gordon that's right
nice to see you guys
uh what an incredible place oh thank you
it's different it looks like somebody
spent a lot of money yeah we did
how much did you spend building this
place i think it's around six billion
wow and what's it worth now
oh probably two
two million um we need help jordan uh
yeah well i'm here to help i mean
driveway yeah woodland stunning i mean
absolutely
walk in there inside it's
it's caked in dust in there it's not
supposed to be oh it it is trust me okay
and then the hamasa horror for me was
going up there have you been up there
recently uh probably about a month ago
disgusting flies everywhere not a dozen
a couple of hundred okay thousands let
me give it to you straight it looks like
staff are taking the piss going upstairs
for a break putting their cigarettes in
a bottle on the back of one really bad
fire the last thing you want to get is a
second one that's true so you're the
general manager i am running it and i'm
trying jimmy started a little over a
year ago right but he's so tied with the
restaurant so
jimmy runs the kitchen and you do
everything else so that's a lot on your
plate oh i open the kitchen too i do the
ordering i do the ordering
how come he doesn't do his own ordering
oh he would if i told him to right yeah
but everything on your shoulders running
this place yeah i guess i'm used to it
yeah wow
so um i've never done anything like this
before so it's unfound territory for me
okay in order for me to see where the
cracks are what this place is made of
how good we are
i've found an amazing couple that
recently just got engaged
and due to the circumstances with the
groom he's having to
go off and do military duty in two weeks
time oh okay so
they
are coming here
and we
are gonna host their wedding
okay when are we done in a couple of
days
okay and it's a very important 100 yes
100 years okay 100 so i need to see how
this place functions and what you've got
what the standards are like just the
kind of offerings okay look at it it
should have way more than 30 or 40
events a year
it doesn't make sense
knowing the castle is losing money by
not hosting as many weddings as they
should be i wanted to see how i could
improve their standards and increase
revenue roxanne yeah nice to meet you
likewise hi good to see eric how are you
so i invited a bride and groom to get
married at the castle first of all let
me say congratulations thank you yeah i
know you're trying to get married
quickly because you're uh off yeah
on duty and so we want to make this uh
somewhat special yeah we're doing this
once and there's no rehearsal right
right let's jump in shall we okay
perfect please it's my first time here
ours too there we go
oh dear it looks like someone's puked on
the walls uh with a lemon rag pie oh
dear that's ceiling
really scary chairs
oh dear those are really stainless
what their spandex yeah they're they're
not nice aren't they i don't know dude
that's worse oh dude i do
[Music]
i'm melody hi
sam roxanne yes yes thank you so much
eric welcome to the castle um let's talk
about the food and what do you normally
do normally we do buffets buffets wow
that's something from the 1980s so what
do we do with tasting the buffet we
don't do tastings you don't do tastings
we don't do tastings no why not because
of the kitchen staff the setup in the
kitchen not really selling me on a good
wedding so you can stay relaxed for now
but trust me we're going to taste some
food we're going to take a seat we're
going to do some tastings and i'd like
to see a menu um don't worry okay
get this sorted okay you go there my
daddy please probably got too many set
here take a seat please before we do the
tasting is the owner's son here jimmy
he's the he's in charge
can we have a quick chat yep jerky yeah
uh color's dreadful reception lobby
awful
the linens don't even match
there's white and ivory there's a lot
going on at the on the bars i'm not sure
if that's left over from another morning
dreadful
jimmy yeah uh
shepherd he'd like to meet you okay
hi you are jimmy i'm jimmy good to see
you nice to meet you spoke to mum
earlier yes
to uh two very special guests of roxanne
hi there nice to meet you roxanne and
here i'm eric nice to meet you as well
um so do you have a chef jacket or i do
did you ever wear it or um when only
when i deliver food
deliver like bring food out to people
obviously just put the jacket on to
carry food yeah so i look fancier
so you normally wear a t-shirt to cook
yeah and pants
and pants yes that's very kind of yeah
yes anything you recommend i mean try to
sell it a little bit the bride and groom
um
there's certain things i have never made
before so uh that probably stopped two
seconds yes you've got things on your
menu that you've never made before well
no one's ever ordered them
but you run a restaurant here yes that's
not a buffet no i plated i should
definitely know how to make them i agree
yeah
i've never cooked a filet mignon before
you've never cooked a filet mignon no
who cooks it we've never sold one
so no one's ever had a wedding in order
fillet not since i've been here not for
me you've got things on here you've
never cooked before yeah
correct so just out of interest filet
mignon comes on you're gonna go to a
culinary school what happens maybe
google
how to do it exactly
yes
google a filet yeah
just to watch a video uh yes
our wedding food is really good well i
can't wait to taste it uh let's have a
look at this and okay yeah i'll see you
later sounds good wow okay sorry about
that
after learning jimmy gets these recipes
from the internet i'm starting to feel
like i made a mistake inviting the bride
and groom to have their wedding here so
we have a
to give some options for roxanne and
eric i told jimmy to prepare a selection
of dishes
up first a chicken dish that i couldn't
believe was smothered in soggy cheese
look at that with uh it's not my
granddad's foreskin
no good i want the grandma's to get
upset at night okay
over medium heat add olive oil let it
get hot while jimmy surfed the internet
for how to cook a filet mignon let the
fillets
let the fillets eat a hot pan
we were served a salmon dish i mean what
i wouldn't feed that to my cat it is
bland it's undercooked
it's simply drawn in the middle it's
slimy
and knowing jimmy had never cooked a
filet mignon trust me my expectations
weren't high that steak is terrible
that's how it cooks you'd cook better
than that at home wouldn't you yeah now
i know why there's no tastings available
i mean terrible terrible terrible towel
i'm embarrassed and i just want to
apologize i was expecting it way better
than this yeah i mean us too i think gf
be patient let me get the bottle of this
okay okay
it's clear the castle standards are low
and with only two days to put together a
wedding i'm feeling a lot of pressure
and i don't want to disappoint roxanne
and eric
hi hello how are you are you well good
how are you guys feeling discouraged i
mean
you know it's an important day for us
and
the food's really important and it's
like i think about this and i want it to
be the best day of my life and then it's
disappointing
it's something you want people to
remember for a good reason not a bad
yeah exactly you know i see lots of
young couples and we host lots of
weddings but
there's new territory for me i've never
seen a space member of staff so
disconnected to the real deal i don't
think we thought it was gonna be like
this
there's only two days till roxanne and
eric's wedding and having witnessed the
lack of attention to the event space and
menu
tonight i need to see how marta and
jimmy run their restaurant on a regular
night
hey how are you tj tj good to see you
and this is
i'm shayla shayla nice to see you i'm
jimmy's wife oh jimmy's wife yeah chess
wife cook's wife general manager's wife
yes right what is he a gm or a coke a
little bit of both a little bit both yes
excellent good answer okay good what do
you do tj i'm just the host tonight
excellent
so
so
so we'll [ __ ] up
jimmy the sea bass what about it it
needs to go on it's just with this
disorder i don't uh good evening good
evening hey gordon
she has a bruschetta listed here too
six months on that
we haven't met you have we no no grant
grant good to see you are you a sous
chef yes
i know you work in the kitchen tonight
as well
yeah i'm sort of helping wow what don't
you do in this establishment
nothing
[Music]
yeah i can't think of anything
[Music]
holy crap so you can call the fish and
meat on the same plate
uh we do the meat on the left side and
the fish on the right side
it's all the same flat yes so you're
saying everything on the left doesn't
hit the right and everything on the
right doesn't hit the left
i've never seen that okay
it's where the food sits there sherlock
yes sir why do they put food here is
this what they this is the warmers yes
this is the on the wall
yes
this is what we have
it's crazy
jesus but where's the kitchen's in there
they just stick this on the wall so how
do you know whose is whose you just pick
up we take the wrong plates all the time
what a [ __ ] up scenario that is
what is this is this done i think so i
don't have any idea what all this meat
goes to right now
what are these two flatirons for does
anybody know oh
here's a flat iron medium rare there's a
flat iron but i don't know what tables
they go to
jesus
[ __ ] mate um i've never said that is a
beef socket off what's that just
just show me that one oh a beef
stroganoff yeah yes bring it down please
yes
tile's hard to make
i mean it looks like prison food whose
table is that stocking off that's mine
that's yours and what are you waiting
for now
um the rest that was uh on a single
ticket but there were six of them
seriously
why is it not all the same ticket
well because they wanted separate bills
so i just i wrote them all on separate
tickets because that's how we but you do
that at the end the kitchen needs one
ticket so they can serve all the entrees
together
let's go
oh my god
omg
what are you waiting for my donny um
i was talking off
where are we at here one french fry
okay do we have anything on the sixth
top what's she waiting on stroganoff's i
guess
this doesn't really have any sauce in it
but i can't
i can't help it that guy messed up just
take it
uh you just deserve better i'm sorry
oh here's your song enough
ten minutes later
there we go your plate's hot too so be
careful yours looks completely different
wow what a mess what a mess
oh geez
[Music]
jimmy that's been sat there 15 minutes
now this one which has this one here
what is it yeah what are you waiting on
i've just i've never seen this kind of
dysfunctional kitchen so one dish three
minutes later another dish comes along
and the girls are coming up and seeing
the flat iron seeing the chicken and
just going because there's no uniform
the table's been waiting where's your
tickets right there okay
just take this medium rare flat iron
then i guess we apparently need another
castle did we make that or not someone
must have
taken the ticket down without us knowing
this steak was supposed to be medium
and the other lady her potatoes garlic
mashed were ice cold
oh
they want it more well done
she wants they want it more well done
the same piece or an old another one no
we'll have to put it back on i don't
know
i've gathered that the restaurant has
absolutely no organization but what is
more alarming is how dependent jimmy is
on his mother to run this business
[Music]
we did it that was easy
uh
i'm not gonna laugh
let's just go back to the beginning
driving in and look at the place
breathtaking
walking the reception and it's just
caked in dust
and that tower in front of the entrance
is laden with 5 000 dead flies
tonight i just wanted to see how this
place functioned and hand on heart i've
never seen such a dysfunctional business
in all my life
surely you must know that this is not
right
i i think we know that but you think
i'm
i speak for myself and i can say i know
that and yeah everybody walks around us
we're doing a great job and laughing and
joking as if to say we got something to
be proud of
i wouldn't say we're in denial no
[ __ ] i got told when i checked in
jimmy is the general manager
can i just tell you the feeling
when you walk into this place
there's no authority there's no
responsibility and staff are just going
through the motions
and if you are even going to attempt to
step up to that position you can't go
home pat yourself on the back saying
you're doing a great job you need to
start implementing
gordon we would like this to be the
starting point of that you know we want
that
we just
you know you get a little overwhelmed
and you don't know
you know how to proceed
the the general consensus in this
building is that you are generally
running around seven days a week for
everybody
that's true
and tonight i witnessed it first hand
this is no life for any lady in the 60s
no it isn't banging the head against the
wall that is not right can i just have
two minutes with your mother on my own
please yes
this is insane honestly you look like
the pot washer's assistant tonight i
know
sometimes i am the partner
seriously
yeah
i think i've gotten so used to it
and so i just keep doing it you're doing
more and more every week every month
every year and it's not right
and that must be having a toll somewhere
you can't continue like this i agree
has your son
taken enough responsibility
i think that
he probably feels that he has because
he's never
probably had the life that i've had to
know what it's like to
work from morning to night he's never
felt the jeopardy that you do on a daily
basis
no nowhere near it no one has and it
shows he knows you're going to do it and
that's the problem and he's got so used
to that
that he's not going to come out of his
comfort zone and do any more because he
doesn't need to
i want jimmy to wake up and take the
burden off your shoulders
and step up and start showing some form
of responsibility
you should think about a letter about
what you need from him going forward
think about something strong and speak
openly
and if you can commit that to me then
i'm gonna commit myself to you and get
in this place okay back on the map
okay yeah
promise i promise thank you
okay get some rest okay okay
it's very important for hotels that host
weddings to not only focus on the event
itself but other services as well front
desk i'd like to order this 79
breakfast in bed package so i ordered a
room service package for roxanne and
eric enjoy you guys enjoy
we will see you soon all right
i'd check in on you how is it it tastes
uncomfortable oh god it's just going
from bad to worse
my apologies after seeing their
disappointment and that nothing was
special about the experience i sent
someone from my team to put together a
gift basket to show how much higher
their standards
really need to be this is just basic
stuff you two dig in we've got some work
to do
last night i asked marta to write a
letter to jimmy outlining her needs for
him moving forward
i'm hoping this can show jimmy he needs
to step up
okay
um
how long did it take to put this thing
together probably uh
an hour hour and a half to think about
it
i want to sleep around 5 a.m what you
went to sleep at 5 am why
uh
just thinking about everything that went
on and
wishing it wouldn't have been the way it
was
knowing
there's a lot to fix and
just being
completely
overwhelmed at all the
aspects of it so
i have a lot of nights like that
that's exactly what he needs to hear and
that's what we've got left in order to
get through to him that's where he needs
to feel your pain a little bit because
you've been too good masking over it
yeah
i yeah i do probably do that a lot you
need to stop accepting everything to
make things better for yourself now and
that's been so easy on your son and
being a little bit more selfish because
you're too kind too generous right i
agree with that you need a break yeah
quit
yeah you're right
okay thank you
[Music]
uh joey two seconds please
take a seat
your mother she left last night yes
upset
i want you to listen to something
important yes i just want you to listen
okay
um
dear jimmy
i worked 20 years at the coloring book
factory being on call 24 7. i of course
thought that when we sold the business
we would retire
unfortunately that didn't happen
i know you have always seen me work hard
but the financial part of it has been
just as stressful
it is so disheartening when we could get
complaints about such stupid things as
dust and uncleanliness it has to stop
there's no excuse for it it has to
change
no one has more to gain by making the
castle successful than you do
let's make this place what it should be
a great future for all of us love moms
[Music]
i just want to say thank you
i know
i know
i love you
[Music]
you know this can't continue
and where i'm coming from it's about
stepping up that means putting mum out
of the day-to-day running are you
getting
firm
strong
and making some serious [ __ ]
decisions
i don't want you have the impression
that i'm i'm too proud or i'm a spoiled
brat because how much do you want this
i will i
i don't know if there's a real word for
it but i want it i want
i mean
can i just have two minutes with him yes
please
in the kitchen get yourself a coffee and
close that door
i don't [ __ ] feel it enough
that's all i don't get
excited by it
she
your mother hasn't got long left at this
pace and if you've got a pair of balls
you better start [ __ ] using them and
i want you to use them quick
i don't think you fully understand
just what a gift you've got i don't
think i do either i
i feel it but i don't
fully have a grip of it no
and whilst i am here i want to see you
commit okay and show me how hungry you
are oh well yes sir and when you see
something wrong say something [ __ ]
sort it out like your mum's been doing
oh well got it got it
[Music]
it's the day before the wedding and
preparations are underway normally we
have a soft drink soda station on the
antique down there while the staff
discussed last minute details with
roxanne and eric my team and i are
completely making over the event space
we're upgrading the drab interior with a
modern decor to brighten up the room and
create an inviting space
[Music]
are you ready can we run
let's go okay brace yourselves yeah what
you're about to see is mine playing
jump in oh my goodness welcome
oh my god oh my goodness come on in oh
my goodness
oh my god
oh wow where shall we start oh my god
just the lighting a lot it feels more
inviting it's a different world gone is
that ghastly yellow color oh it's
beautiful melody oh beyond what i ever
could have imagined i can't believe it's
the same place that's awesome
complete
new paneling all the way around
wow absolutely breathtaking
so let's have a little focus on the
tables brand new chairs oh my goodness
it's amazing beautiful take a seat
now we have proper elegant chairs look
at the chargers aren't they beautiful
check out the floor
brand new floor yeah so nice look at the
space over there now with the bar so
nice like it's like out of a magazine
this is what it's like during the day
can you imagine what it's gonna be like
at night
with the candles later
yeah
this is what we've needed i mean we we
need guidance and we've been spinning
our tires for so long great and you're
happy i'm happy
i'm probably the most excited i've been
except maybe when my babies and
grandbabies were born
i'm literally that excited oh my it's so
beautiful thank you so much
yes
[Music]
now
let's talk food
yes ladies come and line up here
let's take one of each menus
i've got a plan for the food let's focus
first on the menu in place for the
restaurant
let's start off at the beginning
french onion soup and a bowl of chili oh
wow we've got the beef stroganoff with
wild mushrooms oh yeah
next to that you've got the chicken
alfredo i like that yeah let's focus on
the big menu for the wedding tonight
the perfect
entree is the braised short ribs oh
beautiful
next to that we've got a local walleye
it's amazing beautifully see it
oh look at that oh that's beautiful
nothing complicated wow everything looks
so appetizing too uh clean yes yeah but
there is one thing missing and that's a
chef so i've arranged for a unique
person that has been working with me in
vegas for the last five years she is
incredible and she's going to be your
consultant chef okay let me introduce
you to akisha
good morning we're going to stand here
this young lady knows her stuff she's
going to help to instill somebody on a
full-time basis okay but the handover
process is going to be part of her
responsibility are you excited great
very excited grant
work closely with her absolutely now
remember tonight you're going to step up
and run this the burden is now on your
shoulders i'm prepared to take it
[Music]
morning hello hello gorgeous come on
ladies
how are you amazing when i check in with
roxanne and eric to assure them that
everything's on track with their wedding
hey feeny very good yeah yeah i just
want to give the heads up room's looking
gorgeous
okay now let's just set him up i put
jimmy in charge of managing the entire
event from the ceremony to the reception
it's a cool layout oh in it pretty here
with the sun coming now yeah it is
pretty while the castle has done many
events in the past i'm hoping this
wedding not only raises the bar but puts
it on the map as a destinational spot
jan tower you look great by the way ah
so smart
all good you look smart as well yeah
where's eric he's already out there um
how are we looking looks great so yeah
everything's beautiful quick here's the
bride the bride's coming everybody
wow
sure it's gorgeous as they sit down
let's go into the room and let's just go
over everything get the team together
and we'll get our timings absolutely
nailed welcome everyone to this
beautiful glorious day of the union of
roxanne
and eric
so you guys aren't used to doing yeah
service it's being buffet after buffer
that's gone say goodbye to the 1970s
welcome to the 21st century one it's on
finesse it's a wedding it's not a
funeral so be happy we get in the weeds
we get ourselves out it's not a race
guys who's the general manager jimmy
jimmy excellent who's in charge of the
kitchen great that's right talk
communicate any uh last words of advice
for the team um just stay positive you
know it's their big day we don't want
them to see our problems yeah good luck
guys yeah thank you thank you let's go i
now pronounce you husband and wife you
may kiss your bride
[Music]
[Applause]
all right everybody uh i hope you
enjoyed the ceremony we're gonna head
over to the uh the event hall
right ladies help sit them down got it
please quick as you can
table five right here's table 11
what would you like i didn't do the
short ribs please
so here we go grant takes every ticket
and don't accept a ticket until you
understand it absolutely okay that's the
only way the fish the fish i'm gonna do
the walleye walleye okay very good
okay so you've got to synchronize with
the dj to announce the bride and group
big moment this one yes okay so focus on
the timing yes yep
how are you so when you walk back in
that's when you cue the dj yeah because
the dj is going to make the announcement
ladies and gentlemen be upstanding for
the bride and groom yeah this is a
crucial moment now yes sir i'm gonna go
up there right now and talk to them and
find out what exactly when they're
exactly coming down as soon as i come
back in the room
um you'll see me walk in the door so be
kind of looking as soon as i walk in but
you have to get everyone's attention
yeah yeah
what's all this for you've all we're
only doing the brightest you want to get
their pronunciation
for the bride and groom it's just
roxanne and eric
you don't have their last name no jimmy
how to announce the bride and groom
please be upstanding for mr and mrs mr
and mrs
is it or gallardy
is the pronunciation
jimmy you should have this nailed that's
what that's called gulari or gallardy
pilati hilarity i don't want to [ __ ] up
with the bride and groom okay so we have
to be [ __ ] seamless
good luck mm-hmm i'll confirm it
we're going to get something you just
wait outside for me okay yep
oh my gosh
i'll let you tell the dj how to
pronounce your last name correctly all
right you couldn't have been like the
smiths or something right
okay so i'm gonna go in and kind of get
everyone's attention and go ahead and
give me how do you want you would like
to be introduced mr and mrs eric waldoni
the bride and groom are two minutes away
okay be careful yes ladies and gentlemen
if i could have your attention please we
have a very special couple right outside
that door and we would like to give them
a big welcome as they enter the room
let's have a nice round of applause for
the new mr and mrs eric waldoni
at this time they are going to be making
their way to the dance floor to share
their first dance together as husband
and wife
[Applause]
[Music]
we're now seventy entrees just make sure
all the asparagus are lining the same
way this the ends are together like so
yes five plates please grant service
please that's the top table i'm going to
give it to the bread
second table yeah four fish too big yes
everything look nice oh my gosh the
presentation is beautiful awesome yes i
love it good to hear i'll come back and
check on you soon take any plates out of
your way here you're good
shayla why are we clearing when the
whole table hasn't finished um
so [ __ ] wrong so wrong
so his plate is clear and she's like
playing with the food yeah so from a
woman's point of course she does so you
know that so this is what i'm saying to
you all right i can't tell you the
obvious because you know this [ __ ]
okay
yeah and i want them looked after like
one two and so do you right yes i'm
gonna see if they want any more
champagne right now yeah okay
i'm gonna come back with some champagne
to top everybody off okay
the
atmosphere in here is incredible did it
i mean it really is however jimmy needs
to be on top of things right yeah he
needs to know the small attention
details okay yeah just look at the
atmosphere the difference is night and
day yep they're happy let's keep them
that way no okay get the staff to do
that put that down okay okay you're the
owner i know you are the owner you're
asking me to go get beer and go here
they're picking up after you you're not
picking up after that those days have
gone okay thank you
how was dinner i'm waiting for my wife
to pass over plates
how's everything tasting beautiful
[Applause]
you too uh my time is done
uh what a day that's amazing seriously i
mean really have you had a good day
thank you today was perfect
absolutely perfect everything that
she could have asked for that i could
have asked for it's been phenomenal
thank you both for your patience because
when we first met at the beginning of
the week i was more nervous than you too
good luck to you both thank you so much
thank you
thank you take care i totally thought
when we first got here we're settling
this isn't what i want but we need to do
this quickly and now it is the fairy
tale that you think when you see a
castle it's jaw-dropping the
transformation that was made
how are you feeling first i'm feeling
great the ceremony was amazing
who's the general manager jimmy is who's
the owner i am that's right and you
just oversee it okay i don't want you
chasing trash cans i know i don't want
you sweet
look after yourself okay okay thank you
i need 30 seconds with your son okay
goodbye
i appreciate it enjoy this place i will
okay i will you deserve it thanks so
much good night good night
i do not want to see your mom sweeping
up i don't either you need to step up i
couldn't believe you forgot the name of
the bride and goon yes that was bad
however your mind's in the right place
do not be scared of change tonight was a
little rough yeah but think of the
difference you made on that young couple
i know they've seemed so appreciative of
everything and the first thing they do
they're going to tell all their friends
yes this amazing wedding they've had yes
you're going to promise me you're going
to stay on track i'm going to put in the
work i promise good luck thank you thank
you have a safe trip thank you good
night yeah
thanks gordon
wow
[Music]
since my last visit landau's mohican
castle has steadily increased their
bookings
keisha has reorganized the kitchen
and with jimmy's help they have found a
new head chef to take the lead and jimmy
has finally taken charge as general
manager let's make a plan and figure out
what we want to do timing wise allowing
his mother to take a step back as an
owner
you